[Musica]
buongiorno io vi parlerò delle fake news
nei social network l'efes news sono
sempre esistite perché si tratta delle
notizie false delle notizie in stato un
grande cambiamento c'è stato un grande
cambiamento perché noi siamo passati da
quelli che erano i vecchi mezzi di
comunicazione di massa a un grande mezzo
di comunicazione per le masse i mezzi di
comunicazione di massa sono la radio le
televisioni i giornali nei mezzi di
comunicazione di massa c'è un mediatore
culturale
il mediatore culturale è quella persona
che ha il compito di stabilire questa
cosa si può pubblicare questa cosa non
si può pubblicare la persona che decide
eventualmente anche una censura nei
confronti delle notizie
ecco su internet e in particolar modo
nei social network non c'è un mediatore
culturale non sono sistemi di broadcast
questo significa che chiunque può
pubblicare una notizia può pubblicare un
idea e la può diffondere e questo è un
grandissimo strumento di democrazia
diretta nelle nostre mani è un
potentissimo strumento di democrazia che
però ha un lato negativo un aspetto
negativo che ovviamente rappresentato
dalle fake news che oggi stanno
influendo massivamente su quella che è
la politica di tanti paesi e su quella
che è la vita ovviamente anche politica
in italia
allora perché sono qui a parlarvi di
questo perché il 30 novembre del 2014
avevo finito di fare le elezioni ero a
casa mia a teramo
ho gettato un occhiata distratta ai
social network e gettando questo
occhiata distratta i social network
facebook ho visto che i miei studenti i
miei colleghi gli avvocati insomma gli
utenti di facebook stavano massivamente
copiando incollando sulla propria
bacheca questo messaggio questo
messaggio che cos'è è un disclaimer a
tutela della privacy
quella che vedete è una delle tante
versioni di questo messaggio che dice
attenzione a partire da domani tutti i
tuoi dati sarà
uno di proprietà di facebook perché lo
stabilisce il trattato di roma e se vuoi
proteggerti da questo se vuoi tutelare
la tua privacy
quello che devi fare non è condividere
mi raccomando ma copiare e incollare
copiare incollare questo messaggio sulla
tua bacheca e in quel modo potrai
difenderti dalle violazioni alla tua
privacy
allora io insegno informatica giuridica
oltre che filosofia del diritto mi rendo
conto immediatamente che questa cosa non
può essere vera faccio un rapido
controllo sui motori di ricerca per
vedere le leggi perché venivano citate
delle leggi capisco che è una
sciocchezza e penso adesso voglio
scrivere una smentita per i miei
studenti e quindi su quella che è la mia
pagina pubblica di facebook mi seguivano
allora 840 studenti e la usavano
essenzialmente per rivedere l'orario
delle lezioni per capire quando avrei
dovuto fare una conferenza oppure
l'orario degli zani quella pagina
io scrivo la mia smentita la mia
smentita e questo avviso agli studenti
di informatica giuridica in cui scrivo
chiunque tra di voi avesse condiviso una
sorta di disclaimer a tutela della
privacy è pregato di uscire da facebook
con david betania cosmo persone lasciare
la facoltà di giurisprudenza e
iscriversi a scienze degli snack al
formaggio andiamo male ragazzi molto
molto male
scrivo questa cosa pensando
nella mia testa c'era l'immagine dei
miei studenti che sorridevano in quel
momento cioè la mia idea era lì voglio
far sorridere scherzando su questa
bufala che sta circolando in questo
momento e poi inizia a vedere le
visualizzazioni il counter delle
visualizzazioni sulla mia pagina
facebook che inizia a crescere e quindi
1.000 2.000 3.000 10mila 100mila
visualizzazioni
penso c'è qualcosa che non va qui si è
rotto qualcosa
non è possibile che io faccio 100.000
visualizzazioni in tre ore in quattro
ore
qualcosa non funziona probabilmente in
una settimana
questo messaggio ottiene un milione e
500mila visualizzazioni è diventato
contro virale
cioè è come se avesse guarito in qualche
maniera una piccola parte della rete da
un virus informazionale che stava
girando che era il messaggio a tutela
della privacy la mia smentita finisce su
tutti i giornali
mia madre la trova su donna moderna che
rappresenta un po l'apice della mia
carriera come le blogger
è questa che è la mia pagina pubblica
passa da 800 follower a 5 mila follower
in una settimana
a quel punto io inizio a dedicarmi alla
pagina pubblica al blog e inizia a fare
tra le altre cose attività di di banking
che è una cosa di cui vi voglio parlare
oggi il di banking e quelle attività che
svolge chi va a smentire le bufale le
notizie inventate i coqs le fake news
che girano in rete
e io lo faccio soprattutto in ambito
giuridico perché la mia preparazione mi
consente quando leggo qualcosa di
sbagliato qualcosa di equivoco sui
poteri del presidente della repubblica
su come si forma un nuovo governo sulle
leggi a tutela degli animali
mi consente di intervenire sulla
legittima difesa e spiegare ai miei
follower che le cose vanno viste in un
certo modo perché ho le competenze per
farlo e provo a farlo ovviamente in una
forma che per loro deve essere anche
accattivante perché quello che voglio
fare è diventare contro virale rispetto
ai messaggi sbagliati che inquinano la
rete che ha un pozzo dal quale tutti
andiamo a bere per ottenere informazioni
allora come sono fatte queste sehic news
queste fake news queste notizie
inventate che rovinano la qualità
dell'informazione e quindi in qualche
maniera incidono sulla politica vi
dicevo prima del paese esistono diversi
tipi di fei che ci sono delle fake
soltanto di tesco dove c'è scritto
qualcosa come quella sulla privacy che
abbiamo visto prima
ci sono delle fake e che hanno a corredo
una foto questo è molto importante
le fake di foto funzionano benissimo
basta mettere una foto e sottoscrivere
una didascalia un ad e scalia che dice
vedete questa persona nella foto è la
nipote del ministro lazzaroni lei
percepisce 300 mila euro al mese per non
fare nulla
condividi se sei indignato queste fake
hanno un grandissimo successo perché per
le persone l'immagine è la prova
inconfutabile che quello che c'è scritto
è vero si fermano all'immagine me l'hai
provato me l'hai fatto vedere
e poi c'è un terzo tipo di fake che
lavorano su un fenomeno che si chiama
click dating il sic dating è quel
fenomeno per cui qualcuno condivide su
jean network il link a una notizia che
si trova su un sito e la notizia può
essere di qualsiasi tipo le persone
vanno a cliccare sul link per avere la
notizia è la persona che ha diffuso
quella notizia guadagna molto in termini
di pubblicità
qual è quindi la forma qual è la
sostanza del fake minus dal punto di
vista della forma le freak news fanno
anche qualcosa di positivo che non viene
mai abbastanza ricordato del quale non
si parla mai abbastanza
questa cosa positiva è che le fake news
diventano virali come vi dicevo prima
diventando virali squarciano il filter
bubble diventando virali distruggono la
camera dell'eco che cos'è questa camera
dell'eco è uno dei motivi per i quali
vengono criticati social network cioè si
dice che nei social network
noi tendiamo a parlare solo con le
persone che la pensano come noi e quindi
entriamo in una sorta di camera dell'eco
in cui io dico qualcosa e gli altri che
la pensano tutti come me ripetono la
stessa cosa che ho detto
ecco se è vero che esiste questo
problema del filter bubble della camera
dell'ego è altrettanto vero che le fake
anno strutturalmente architettonicamente
un aspetto positivo per che attraversano
con un tracciante il cielo della rete e
uniscono milioni di persone che
altrimenti non sarebbero mai entrata in
contatto e magari iniziare a discutere
su quell'argomento se c'è un piccolo un
piccolissimo aspetto positivo delle fei
che questa capacità di diventare virali
e di squarciare quindi questi limiti che
ci sono sui social network dal punto di
vista della sostanza the famous possono
riguardare qualsiasi cosa la cosa
importante che devono creare allarme
sociale ci colpiscono emotivamente ci
devono spaventare perché in questo modo
noi saremmo portati a condividere quella
fake e quindi a distribuire questo virus
all'interno della rete all'interno del
sistema informazionale il cuore del
discorso che volevo farvi io oggi e
questo cioè il problema essenzialmente è
perché ci crediamo
per quale motivo noi caschiamo in questa
trappola che la trappola delle fake news
proviamo a riflettere su questo perché
riflettendo su questo
capiremo come possiamo difenderci
il primo motivo per il quale noi ci
crediamo e che le fec news non sono
semplicemente delle balle
non si tratta solo di inventare delle
cose non è una grande fantasia c'è
qualcosa di più le fake news nascono
modificando leggermente la realtà è una
leggera perfetta e una leggera
distorsione della realtà quella che
accade per esempio qualche giorno fa si
è diffusa la notizia in rete che una
nota donna di spettacolo italiana era
morta era venuta a mancare ovviamente
non è vero per fortuna non è vero ma
sappiamo tutti che una persona è
gravemente malata oppure avete visto la
fei che sulla privacy
in quel periodo nel 2014 e stava
facebook stava aggiornando la sua
privacy policy e stava avvisando tutti
quanti gli utenti che avrebbe cambiato
la privacy policy e quindi in quel
momento inizia a circolare la fake news
sulla privacy le persone ci credono c'è
una distorsione della realtà qualcosa
che deve essere verosimile è che ci
viene presentato come vero il secondo
motivo per il quale noi tendiamo a
credere alle fec news e che viviamo
immersi in un flusso continuo di
informazioni
analizziamo questa frase perché è una
frase con la quale possiamo essere
facilmente d'accordo cerchiamo di capire
di quali elementi si compone questo
flusso è una sorta di stream of
consciousness alla joyce
allora prima di tutto dal punto di vista
temporale
noi siamo sempre raggiunti da
informazioni in qualsiasi momento mentre
siamo al semaforo mentre aspettiamo di
entrare dal medico in chiesa le persone
guardano continuamente il cellulare
queste informazioni che ci raggiungono
continuamente provengono da fonti
diverse
quindi arriva un messaggio whatsapp
arrivano sms arriva un messaggio su
facebook qualcuno ha commentato un tuo
post ha commentato qualcosa che hai
scritto provengono da fonti eterogenee
hanno quindi anche un significato
diverso e quindi ovviamente un amico ti
invita andare a giocare a calcetto
qualcun altro vuole parlare di politica
e hanno anche una forma diversa perché
sono multimediali perché ovviamente ci
raggiungono dei messaggi audio su
whatsapp dei messaggi scritti sms dei
video su youtube
facebook mettiamo insieme tutte queste
cose tantissime informazioni ci
raggiungono in ogni momento provengono
da fonti diverse hanno un contenuto
diverso hanno una forma diversa questo
abbassa drammaticamente il livello della
nostra attenzione e quindi più
facilmente cadiamo vittime delle fake
news
in particolare terzo motivo per il quale
crediamo alle fake news è rappresentato
da un nostro vizio da un problema se
volete del modo in cui noi leggiamo il
relativo al modo in cui noi leggiamo i
bambini leggono lettera per lettera e
poi ricompongono le parole leggono
parola per parola e poi ricompongono le
frasi noi adulti abbiamo uno stile di
lettura totalmente diverso ci sono molti
esperimenti di psicologia cognitiva che
dimostrano questo in maniera
inequivocabile gli adulti identificano
la prima e l'ultima lettera di una
parola e poi ricompongono le lettere nel
proprio cervello cioè non andiamo a
leggere le lettere che si trovano tra la
prima e l'ultima quando abbiamo
identificato la prima e l'ultima
riusciamo a capire di quale parola si
tratta
questo è molto importante perché quando
una notizia proviene da un sito che si
chiama il fatto quotidiano oppure
proviene da un sito che si chiama la
repubblica oppure problema da un sito
che si chiama il messaggero
nessuno si rende conto che quel sito non
è il fatto quotidiano la repubblica non
è il messaggero perché nessuno legge
lettera per lettera
leggiamo la prima e l'ultima lettera e
ci convinciamo che con la notizia vera
perché proviene da una fonte che secondo
noi è attendibile ma in realtà c'è un
soggetto dietro che sta facendo click
day finché sta guadagnando sulla nostra
ingenuità come possiamo quindi
difenderci dalle fake news prestando
attenzione lavorando sul tempo di fronte
a una notizia un messaggio che sembra
strano facciamo fact checking cioè
andiamo a controllare basta inserire
quella notizia su un motore di ricerca e
possiamo facilmente capire se qualcuno
l'ha già smentita ci sono dei siti in
italia che si occupano soltanto di
questo se si tratta di diritto venite a
controllare da me perché me ne occupo
anch'io spessissimo relativamente al
mondo del diritto
leggiamo con attenzione la url cioè la
provenienza della notizia lettera
per lettera in questo modo abbiamo la
possibilità di difenderci possiamo
controllare anche le foto perché google
ti consente anche di controllare sono
foto è effettivamente la foto della
nipote del ministro lazzaroni o non si
tratta di un'altra foto
ovviamente questo significa prestare
attenzione significa investire energie
significa che non possiamo navigare
serenamente e condividere qualsiasi cosa
abbiamo una responsabilità questa è la
mia chiamata alle armi il senso del
messaggio che volevo darvi oggi abbiamo
una responsabilità nei confronti della
comunità a tutti perché i social network
sono uno strumento incredibile di
democrazia di crescita culturale
la nostra possibilità di evolvere tutti
insieme lo slogan della democrazia è
pensare tutti pensare assieme ai social
network rendono questo possibile oggi
vengono demonizzati per le fake news
reagiamo abbiamo la possibilità di
reagire tutti quanti noi
chiunque ha una competenza in un campo
chi è medico che ha chimico chi è
avvocato deve intervenire perché ormai
l'agorà la piazza e virtuale dobbiamo
intervenire smentire le notizie false
evitare di diffonderle
vi racconto una cosa che è accaduta in
america nel 2016 a saint paul
la polizia ferma una macchina nella
macchina ci sono tre persone di colore
due signori il signore la moglie e la
bambina che era seduta nel sedile
posteriore
il signore viene ucciso dalla polizia
per motivi che ancora non sappiamo ci
sono ancora indagini in corso
il poliziotto dopo aver ucciso il
signore che era sceso dalla macchina si
avvicina alla macchina con la pistola
inizia a parlare con la signora che si
trova dentro la macchina la bambina e
lacrime sta urlando nel sedile
posteriore
il poliziotto intima la donna di
scendere il finestrino abbassato il
poliziotto punta contro la donna
la pistola la donna punta contro il
poliziotto cellulare e dice sei in
diretta su facebook
stai attento a quello che fai chi
controlla le informazioni controlla il
mondo
questo è il nostro grande strumento di
democrazia ai social network
abbiamo il dovere di impegnarci per
tenerli puliti per tenerli liberi
dalle fake news che altrimenti
potrebbero definitivamente rovinarli
questo era ciò che volevo dire grazie
per la pressione